[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOY PAYTON: I've had people
come to me at work or just
in the community and say, hey,
I saw in LinkedIn that you
were Google Cloud certified.
I want to find out
more about this.
And these are often
career changers,
or people who discovered,
to their surprise,
that they really liked devops,
or platform engineering,
or some of the
background engineering.
And maybe that wasn't the
job that they were hired for,
but they realized that, wow,
I have some technical skills
and abilities that
I didn't know about.
And in fact, I had a
conversation with someone
who has a lot of information
science experience
but is not a programmer.
She would not consider
herself a programmer.
And she said, can I pursue this?
I said, absolutely.
There are specialty
professional-grade exams
for applications developers,
but this initial associate-level
exam is just a great overview
of lots of different things.
And I said, if nothing else,
what it will do is give you
a chance to learn a lot,
figure out what parts you like
and what parts you don't.